toilets killing down these activists say
Kenya's police need to be held to
account for killings according to a
police oversight body 15 people have
been killed by officers enforcing a
nighttime curfew to slow the spread of
the coronavirus campaigners say there
were more some of them were killed here
in the slums we are going all the way
every ghetto ghetto to get off telling
them to stop killing up our kids mothers
are crying sisters everybody we are all
heart by this injustice of police
brutality the March when the curfew was
introduced in some places it was
enforced with tear gas and beatings this
is 13 year old Yasin Moyo he was shot
dead in Mathari as he stood on his
parents balcony one of the police
officers involved was arrested and
charged with murder last week but it's
rare please to be convicted of crimes in
Kenya when a homeless man was shot dead
in Masari last week residents blocked
roads and burn tires they say police
killed him police have denied it but it
prompted the activists to call for
police officers to face justice you go
up a little I am here to protest for our
youth who have died in the hands of the
police without any wrongdoing and we're
saying enough is enough as mothers many
of our youth have been killed while
being labeled as thieves
Kenya's police was created about a
century ago by British colonialists it
was used to violently put down an
independence movement the campaigners
here say its officers still don't
respect people's rights as people around
the world take to the streets against
racism and police brutality Kenya's
activists are calling for change -
Malcolm Webb al-jazeera
Nairobi Kenya